what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
okay so in today's video on how to kill
superheroes we are going to try
something different and what I mean here
is that whenever we make these videos we
usually focus on characters that are
extremely hard to kill because they're
just incredibly powerful but in this
video we're going to look instead at a
character who's difficult to kill
because of its skill and resourcefulness
instead of a strength and durability and
in this video the character we're going
to be focusing on is Oliver Queen
better known as Green Arrow now before
we go any further I want to address the
elephant in the room right away yes
Green Arrow has no superpowers and yes
Green OH can be killed in any way that
you and I could be killed he can be
killed with a gun or a knife or
basically any other weapon he can be
drowned poisoned and you can even die in
a car accident so from that point of
view green arrow really isn't that hard
to kill per se but just leaving it at
that does not make for a very
interesting video in fact it would be
crappy if we just said hey guys here's
how to kill me now have like a snipers
on the rooftop and shoot him but you
would not be very fun it would be writ
it be really really boring so to make
things more interesting we're going to
set some ground rules first of all we're
taking any super-powered entities out of
the equation and we'll go ahead and
concede that Superman Martian Manhunter
Wonder Woman or any of those
super-powered characters of DC Universe
could easily kill Green Arrow if they
wanted to so there's no need to analyze
that any further and so that leaves us
with only a non powered means of taking
out the Green Arrow and although we have
already established that Green Arrow is
completely immortal there are definitely
attributes that he possesses which may
killing him an extremely difficult task
first of all he's one of if not the most
highly skilled Archer on the planet he's
been said to be able to fire twenty nine
arrows and under a minute and is proven
to have enough accuracy to shoot an
arrow down the barrel of a gun or even
split the drop of water and hat-making
green arrow even more formidable as the
fact that he's able to perform acrobatic
movements without sacrificing any of his
accuracy with his bow and arrow
it's also worth pointing out that green
arrows arsenal extends well beyond
conventional arrows although he does
fire normal arrows
frequently he also has at his disposal a
plethora of triggers including an
exploding arrow a grappling hook arrow
and more infamously a boxing glove arrow
Oliver Queen
has also demonstrated proficiency with a
sword and he's held his own in a fight
with Deathstroke who's one of the most
skilled fighters in the DC Universe and
Green Arrow is also aided in combat by
exceptional strength agility and stuff
so with all that in mind we can see why
this combination makes Green Arrow an
extremely difficult kill for anyone who
does not possess any superpowers any
fighter relying on skill and
hand-to-hand combat or even those who
are equipped with a weapon are going to
find Green Arrow an extremely
challenging foe he's able to move
through the shadows undetected making it
extremely likely that he's going to be
able to get the drop on any opponent and
so giving Green Arrow the element of
surprise is going to make it extremely
difficult for anybody to be able to
defeat him now once engaged in combat
Green Arrow will likely be able to
disarm his assailant with relative ease
and it could use any of the several
arrows in his arsenal however it's at
this point that we encounter one of the
critical weaknesses that can be
exploited to take out Oliver Queen which
is his personal code of ethics that
prevents him from killing his opponent
Oliver Hughes fears of the kill is a
trait that's not uncommon to superheroes
but one that could prove to be his
downfall if he finds himself facing an
opponent that is out to kill as Oliver
will likely pull his punches and keep
his arrow shafts non-lethal while his
opponent would not afford him the same
courtesy another thing that we have to
remember about Oliver's personality is
that like many heroes he surrounds
himself with people that he cares about
and was willingly sacrifice himself if
he needed to this list of people
includes his younger sister amico and
its girlfriend watch Canary as is the
case with almost all the heroes and DC
Comics and even Marvel Oliver would most
likely walk into any situation that he
needed to no matter how vulnerable it
would make him to save either Emiko or
Black Canary now as we said this is
something that can be said about any of
the other heroes but Green Arrow is
exceptionally vulnerable to this due to
his deep sense of empathy one of the
trademarks of Green Arrow's character is
vintage devotion to making life better
for the downtrodden this makes them more
vulnerable than most other heroes
because it wouldn't necessarily even
have to be someone close to him that's
in danger to prompt his self-sacrifice
but could possibly be any person that's
put in harm's way needlessly now apart
from the aspects of Oliver's personality
that we can exploit if we're looking for
a way to kill Green Arrow from a purely
tactical standpoint the key is going to
be to stay out of
range of his bow and arrow now once you
get within range your chances of
survival much less taking out green
arrow would go down significantly with
that in mind we'll need a weapon that
can exceed his arrows range something
like a sniper rifle which might not be
very exciting but might give us the best
shot at taking out Oliver Queen so even
this is not a guarantee to work by any
means sometimes we said earlier Green
Arrow is a master of stealth and
concealing himself so we may simply
never get the opportunity to even take a
shot at him if we end up trying to track
him down in a crowd of people so yeah
this is a pretty short video but when it
comes to somebody like Oliver Queen
that's one of reasons why I've never
really done a video like this before
killing him is pretty straightforward
you can kill him in any number of ways
put at the very least I thought it'd be
interesting to move away from like
wildly super-powered beings for a single
video they kind of transition towards
the direction of focusing on somebody
who's a little easier to kill I guess
but without being said guys next week's
video will be juggernaut so if you guys
are new here to comment explain make
sure you hit the sub button to become
part of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
yeah leave a comment down below cuz I'm
curious about this name off a character
that you think we should kill next
and please don't pick somebody obscure
don't pick like pee or butts like I'm
not going to do a video on how to kill
your puddle it'd be kind of funny
because he's just an eyeball that's
really all he is just like a walking
eyeball but supposed to comment down
below because I'm curious to see what
kind of characters you come up with
do not say well rain because we're
covering him do not wonder we already
covered Wolverines do not say x-23
because that's already scheduled you
don't say spider-man because that one's
already scheduled and don't say Thor
because that one's already sketchbook
I've already got those videos scheduled
out later on down line but uh yeah I'm
curious what you guys come up with and I
will catch you all later please
[Music]